well I've studied acting and I've been
teaching it for a long time I've been
teaching it formally since 1973
and I've taught in all kinds of places
and sometimes I've been required as
would be the case and not now in my
career but certainly early in my career
on a faculty of faculty you know a
faculty has to kind of achieve something
as a group and so a lot of times I've
had to teach very traditional things and
very traditional so I'm oh I know a lot
about the varieties of methods that
there are for approaching acting and I
think the best thing I heard about it
one of my teachers said that up you know
you can't really talk about acting
directly everything that we know to say
is couched in metaphors that's number
one so I like teaching medicine or
teaching architecture or even music
because it has to do with identity and
we don't really understand so much about
it it's not something we can touch or
feel and the changes of identities have
never been for example translated into
music like musical music is translated
into notes we haven't really translated
what we do into something that can be
constantly replicated with the result
that we can anticipate so there's
something about it that's a little
mysterious and then the other thing is
Ethel mermans son actually was one of
the most powerful teachers that I had
and he said simply you know the actors
gift is the imagination and then one
very practical and gifted teacher said
you know acting is the ability that
that you are someone else so people have
all different ways of talking about it
but the first comment I think is the
most honest it's all couched in
metaphors and so I studied a variety of
methods people always made fun of me in
acting school because I was always
taking notes I was very interested in
what is this how is it again that people
can change before my eyes and along the
way of my studying acting and also my
teaching acting I began to see that my
students sounded a lot alike and so I
wanted to show them that no human being
talks like another human being
there are people who are identical like
you can have an identical twin of your
voice like there are people who sound
exactly like a sibling in the tone of
voice but nobody talks alike
and so I thought that one place to study
identity would be in the actual speech
of a given person and originally I was
going around interviewing people because
I wanted to teach something about that
about individuality as it is captured
and in in the actual physical
physiological mechanism of making sounds
we are linguistic animals and then along
the lines of doing that I developed this
method through which I make plays which
is that I interview people I take
something that they said and then I
attempt to say exactly what they said
more than word-for-word utterance for
utterance because I have come to see
that it's in the way the utterances
themselves are manipulated that identity
comes forward so that's what I've been
studying and practicing for a very very
long time and I have to say the thing
that's unquenchable about me is
something I told you about earlier
really what I really really love to do
is to listen to people and listen to
stories and so over the past well I
guess I have to
more than 30 years now if I've been
learning anything it's that I've been
learning more and more about listening
and I never get tired of it never get
tired the goal is to tell a story that
has multiple points of view for the very
reasons that we've been discussing and
to by doing so indicate on an artistic
level that the old idea of the single
even the old idea of the single author
if you will is flawed
because it takes ultimately many people
to tell the story of a community or the
story of a society so that sense of the
Auguste author who can come in and speak
for women and speak for men I don't
believe that is what maybe your
imagination is sufficient maybe not you
know my imagination comes into play but
before doing that I would like to know
how a man feels or how another woman
feels about something
I'm studying that because I understand
that I'm one human being with a set of
experiences that color my lens and I've
always been since I was a little girl
very interested in how that person
across the town across the street how do
they think and understanding I could
never think like they think but wanting
to try to do something about that gap
not even in the humanistic way it was
really something that bothered me it was
really something I worried about so
first of all I hope that by being
present as forty-six people say in
Twilight play about the Los Angeles
Riots and playing a Korean woman whose
store was burned to the ground by
Forked Americans or playing one of the
African American kids who beat up a
white man or playing Daryl gates the
very unpopular chief of police that it
suggests to an audience that they don't
have to sit in their one position and by
the way you know when I come out at the
end and take my curtain call I'm still
me so did I really lose anything know
that maybe I gained something
aesthetically and artistically what I've
been trying to contribute is something
about details that you know maybe
there's a wider variety of human beings
than we've thought about and we can tell
compelling stories without having to
have those same stereotypes that we've
been thinking about over and over again